en attendant revenons à la libération
des trois derniers otages français au
liban
les images se bousculent dans nos têtes
et dans nos esprits nous sommes témoins
de grands moments de joie d'émotion
d'interrogation aussi nous y reviendrons
ce sont ces images que nous allons
privilégier dans un premier temps
ensuite nous essaierons de comprendre
pourquoi et comment on en est arrivé là
en toile de fond il y aura des
témoignages l'historique des
négociations nous évoquerons également
le rôle joué par certains états dans ce
genre d'affaires mais tout de suite
l'image symbole de cette journée celle
que nous avons enregistré ce matin sur
l'aéroport de villacoublay
les retrouvailles sont extrêmement
dignes fallait dire discrète
seuls les enfants ont laissé poindre
leur émotion philippe gassot à son
arrivée jean paul kauffmann à une
hésitation une fraction de seconde il ne
reconnaît pas son fils grégoire et trois
ans c'est une éternité pour un enfant
quand son père est parti en reportage au
liban il avait 11 ans aujourd'hui dans
la 14
les retrouvailles ont été très digne
presque trop comme si des amis se
retrouvaient après une longue absence la
gêne peut être d'avoir changé
kéhi et de n'avoir plus qu'un passé
lointain en commun seuls les enfants qui
ont pendant trois ans révélée
retrouvailles l'espace et leur trop
plein de chagrin
ce sont trois années de l'armée
d'angoissé qui passe la bonde il va
falloir du temps pour se reconnaître
mais c'est fait les familles sont à
nouveau réunis mais journalistes
retrouvent un des leurs enlevés sur la
route de l'aéroport abs clim aurait et
dans toutes les pensées ou il nous a dit
cela c'est un jour formidable bien sûr
aujourd'hui mais
c'est quand même un jour kiki qui est
qui qui reste assombri par le fait que
nous ne sommes que trois et que moi j'ai
été enlevé le 22 mai 1985 avec un homme
qui s'appelait michel seurat gg j'étais
avec lui pendant de longs mois et puis
nous l'avons vu s'éteindre peu à peu et
gg d'une certaine manière j'ai un peu
honte aujourd'hui la d'être leur fab ont
ne jouons pas sur les mots mais c'est sa
demande et un mort c'est le carton et
marcel fontaine on a vu michel seurat
lutter avec avec avec avec désespoir il
ya aussi le dire avec avec avec noblesse
l'aï ils ne s'exprimaient pas beaucoup
il se voyait mourir il a voulu vivre ccc
c'est quelque chose d'affreux et puis
aujourd'hui d'abord et avant tout ma
pensée va à marie sera sa femme je ne
sais pas où elle est actuellement mais
et à ses deux filles
et c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure
avec désespoir il ya aussi le dire avec
avec avec noblesse là ils ne
s'exprimaient pas beaucoup il se voyait
mourir il a voulu vivre ccc c'est
quelque chose de d'affreux et puis
aujourd'hui d'abord et avant tout ma
pensée va à marie sera sa femme je ne
sais pas où elle est actuellement mais
et à ses deux filles
michel au début me disait
puis moi j'ai eu beaucoup de mal
personnellement au début les premières
semaines furent furent affreuse
michel lui était tout à fait bon il
prenait la situation avec une certaine
philosophie les prenais des notes il
écrivait cetera
et puis enfin il disait moi tu sais je
suis prêt à attendre trois ans pour
revoir mes deux filles jeudi a mis trois
ans mais je suis me suis fou tu te rends
compte trois ans et puis bon et c'est
lui qui a disparu nous l'avons vu pour
la dernière fois le 28 décembre 1985
d'étai n'arrivait plus à tenir debout et
il a été transféré dans un endroit côté
de nous de nos cellules de notre cellule
et puis on l'a entendu pendant encore
quelques jours
il tue c'est froid yab le mans il avait
faim cccc c'est quelque chose de
terrible
on était tous les quatre ensemble
on va demander à marcel carton et marcel
fontaine là ils ont vus quotidiennement
là et qui lui tape il savait qu'il a
failli savait pas ce qu'il avait
exactement mais ils savaient qu'ils
allaient que c'était clos x étaient des
espèces il aurait pu
et moi je prends fait il aurait pu
mourir auprès des siens et puis il est
il est mort tout seul c'est quelque
chose d'affreux ça je ne peux pas
l'oublier
nous étions enchaîné depuis le mois de
février l'an dernier après lé là
l'intervention enfin american l'aller
les bateaux là qui s'approchait des
côtes
ç'a eu pour résultat qu'on ne supprime
la radio premièrement et ensuite qu'on
nous pose des chan et puis bon on a eu
des mois j'ai eu les chaînes aux pieds 7
mai compagnon depuis le mois de mai fait
plier
l'an dernier bon on s'y habitue 1 on
revient pas de décompte d'abord il faut
pas exagérer non plus mais c'est sai t
on ou n'a survécu
oui de nombreuses personnalités ont
partagé l'émotion des familles des
otages ce matin sur l'aéroport de
villacoublay
parmi elles madame danielle mitterrand
jacques chirac et charles pasqua
nous reviendrons d'ailleurs assez
longuement tout à l'heure sur les
déclarations du premier ministre dans
quelques instants à nos côté joëlle
kauffmann et et roger haut qu'on ne
présente plus madame kaufmann dans quel
état d'esprit étiez-vous ce matin où
vous avez été très sereine mais y'avait
pas de il n'y avait pas un hobby nous ya
ce forcené sur votre visage ce matin
vite et je me trouve étrangement calme
ça fait trois ans qu'on attendait ce
moment là et on y est j'y croyais encore
pas c'était très très irréel j'ai cru
quand tu entendu les paroles de jean
paul quand même interview de roger quoi
ces erreurs là je me suis reconnu sa
voix tout ça je me suis chez lui c'est
lui c'est lui
j'étais un peu inquiète pour les enfants
il était très bouleversée comme vous
l'avez vu comme pour ne plus louer
c'est une belle image total est
désormais mort je n'ai pas pleuré
pendant trois ans et comme si toute les
larmes des ces trois années de
l'angoissé d'ajouter d'un seul coup
alors c'est vrai on était un peu calme y
avait pas d exubérance et puis cette
arrivée était aussi beaucoup plus qu'un
accident avait été organisée de manière
plus calme pour eux c'est je crois que
c'était mieux mais après cela comment
avez vous trouvé votre marié la mère
solide et sera complètement il a pas
changé c'est un événement pour vous mais
oublie complètement je me disais comme
dans quel état vont s'aimer mais il est
revenu un petit peu comme toi on y parle
énormément il vous avez vu comment il
était bon c'est vrai qu'il parle trop
s'est pas fatigué c'est pas son habitude
quelqu'un de très réservé et très lui
aussi c'est comme s'ils sortaient trois
ans de parole et ça mais
moi j'ai tout fait formidable forcément
mais je savais qu'il serait plongée vous
vous êtes libre depuis le 27 novembre
dans ses recettes et vous avez été
libéré en même temps que jean louis
normandin et c'est vous qui avez réalisé
la première interview de des otages dans
l'avion notamment de notre confrère
jean-louis comment ça s'est passé ce
matin
bagua grâce à certaines informations
j'étais donc à salonique et j'attendais
l'avion qui venait de beyrouth et
lorsque j'ai vu atterrir ce jet privé
venant de beyrouth sur l'aéroport de
salonique
j'étais vraiment très très ému je me
suis avancé vers l'avion j'ai été
autorisé à monter à bord et donc j'ai
j'ai découvert avec a vraiment aidé
beaucoup d'émotion et beaucoup de joie
les trois otages libérés ces trois ans
dont j'avais attendu moi aussi la
libération parce qu'il faut pas oublier
que lorsque j'étais à beyrouth
j'avais couvert leur enlèvement 85 et
donc j'avais toujours suivi cette
affaire deux autres otages notamment
lorsque moi même j'avais été pris en
otage il savait que vous aviez été vous
même mais j'étais assez étonné parce que
la première parole que m'a dit je crois
c'est jean paul kauffmann est aussi
marcel fontaine c'était on était très
inquiet pour toi c'est le pense que
c'est le monde à l'envers
on était très inquiet pour toi parce que
nous avions entendu à la radio que tu
avais été enlevée et nous n'avions pas
nouvelle de toi et et j'étais vraiment
très touché parce et ses premières
minutes durant lesquelles j'étais avec
eux et aussi bon donc leur joie le
sourire de ces trois zones aussi la joie
de jean charles marchiani et de l'autre
négociateurs esponde ars afin qu'ils
étaient très heureux d'avoir réussi leur
mission et je pense que c'était c'est
vraiment une victoire pour tout le monde
sans doute des images vous aussi des
images fortes des images pleines
d'émotions qui se bousculent dans la
tête ça vous rappelez incontestablement
d'autres événements vous aviez connu oui
surtout justement surtout lorsque je
voyais le le sourire très très très
franc de mme arkani et de l'homme
d'affaires libanais lorsqu'il nous
regarder les trois otages et moi en
train de parler en train de faire
l'interview il était tellement satisfait
que que je revivais moi aussi je
revivais les laisser ces moments que
j'avais vécu entre beyrouth et et le
retour à paris dans le dans l'avion
privé
gerald kaufman quelle image conserverait
vous de cette journée c'est peut-être un
peu prématuré car vous aussi il ya des
tas d'image qui se bousculent dans la
tête mais s'il fallait retenir une image
confusément l'image à descendre de
l'avion parce qu'on n'avait pas
contrairement aux autres otages en avait
pas on n'a pas l'image de puisqu'il faut
arriver un temps sur pc comme ça ils
n'ont pas été faits une film est là bas
donc on était là on attendait de voir sa
tête jean paul cécité cc l'image la plus
forte en tout cas ces seuils vous avez
pu parler je suppose avec genre avec
jean-paul quelle que soit la petite
cohue qui avait sur l'aéroport vous at
il parlé de ses ravisseurs
oui c'est pas le syndrome de sokol non
pas du tout depuis laisserait en parler
diamaguène n'y a pas de pardon de sa
part absolument aucune avait alors là je
sais pas si certains mais ça ne me
convient pas du tout aucune aucune
aucune excuse il a une vie parole très
forte à ce sujet là oui je pense qu'il
paraît il parlera mieux tout ça j'espère
que nous l'aurons très bientôt sur le
plateau de mourir au fond vous restez
avec nous madame kaufmann et roger auque
tout au long de cette édition spéciale
dans quelques